okay so this picture has been floating
around Twitter I don't know if you've
seen this let me just show it to you
take a look at this it's it's from a
reporter in Texas and it shows a man
Billy is his name apparently Billy is
voluntarily turning in his gun to police
turning in his ak-47 and of course the
left applauds this kind of thing and
says very well done well well done my
child well done Pat's him on his head
very very good Billy very good but I
really don't get it I mean was the guy
planning a mass shooting if he was
planning a mass shooting then yeah it's
good that he turned in his gun but in
that case he shouldn't just turn in his
gun and say you know you don't want a
guy to come up and say here's my gun
officer I was gonna do a mass shooting
I've changed my mind here's the gun
see you later know there needs to be a
follow-up right like maybe sent him to a
mental health institution at a minimum
or something but if he wasn't planning a
mass shooting which I assume that he was
not then what's the point of turning in
the gun the gun wasn't gonna hurt
anybody it was only gonna hurt somebody
if you were going to hurt them with it
if you weren't planning on that then the
gun poses really zero risk to anyone I
can say that I know for a fact that I am
NOT going to commit a mass shooting I
can say that about myself I can't say it
about anybody else for a fact but I
could say it about myself therefore
there is pretty much a zero percent
chance that my gun will be used for for
a mass shooting it's pretty much zero
there's always I guess the possibility
that it could be stolen or something by
someone who then carries out the mass
shooting but if I'm practicing safe and
responsible gun ownership the chances of
that are very very small so it's
effectively a zero percent chance that
my gun will be used in a mass shooting
which means that I'm not going to give
up my gun in response to a mass shooting
it just doesn't make any sense why would
I this is like it's like I don't know if
if if someone cut off their right leg
amputated they're healthy right leg
because they heard of the case somewhere
else of a guy getting gangrene in his
right leg and then
so it's like it's sort of like that it
just it doesn't make a lot of sense if
you know that you're a responsible gun
owner you're not gonna hurt anybody then
keep your gun there's no reason to get
rid of it speaking of things I don't get
Walmart is the latest company to
surrender to the left on the gun issue
which if I could just say from the
outset before we even look at the before
we even look at the specifics of this
case it makes no sense in general for
Walmart to cave on anything this is
Walmart we're talking about okay this is
Walmart they've got 90 million stores
across across the world they've they
they're worth sixty five trillion
dollars these these numbers are rough
estimates but you get the idea this is a
very big company with lots of money and
lots of power and there is really
nothing the left can do to it especially
in Walmart's case when you consider that
the primary customer base for Walmart is
not going to be wealthy urbanites okay
it's not going to be liberals from you
know in New York or Los Angeles of San
Francisco the the primary customer base
for Walmart is middle-class blue-collar
Americans and so if every liberal in the
country boycotted Walmart which they've
already done in a hundred different
occasions it would amount to what maybe
60 bucks of lost profit I'm making up a
lot of figures to start the show but
I've made up like eight hundred figures
probably but you understand my point
there's just no reason for Walmart to
cave yet it did and we'll talk about
that in just a minute but first you know
nobody really has time to go to the post
office you're busy who's got time for
all the traffic all the parking lugging
your mail and packages evidence just
doesn't it's a real hassle there's no
reason to do it because you have
stamps.com
one of the most popular time-saving
tools for small small businesses
stamps.com eliminates trips to the post
office and it saves you money with
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office so there's just there's no
reason not to do you can go all the way
post office or you can just go on your
computer and go to stamps calm it brings
all
the amazing services of the US Post
Office right to your computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
even if you're a warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day whatever the
case is whatever your needs are stamps
comm can handle it all with ease simply
use your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any package
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send it stands comm is a no-brainer
saving you time and money and so it's no
wonder that over 700 small businesses
already use stamps comm right now my
listeners get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale without any
long-term commitment just go to stamps
comm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Walsh
that's stamps comm enter Walsh and save
time and money alright back to Walmart
reading now from The Daily wire it says
on Tuesday Walmart announced that after
its current inventory is depleted it
will cave to the demands of far-left
activists and stop selling handgun
ammunition and ammunition commonly used
in other popular semi-automatic firearms
walmart also stated that was requesting
that customers excu carrying guns openly
in there roughly 47 I know I pronounced
that word wrong but that's how I
pronounce it askew
roughly 4,700 stores as well as its
Sam's club stores in states that permit
open carry Walmart CEO Doug McMillon
issued a memo to employees on Tuesday in
which he started by citing the mass
shooting in El Paso and in Dayton in
August as well as further mass shootings
and he said will will also be but we've
also been listening to a lot of people
inside and outside our company as we
think about the role we could play in
helping to make the country safer it's
clear to us that the status quo is
unacceptable
Macmillan noted that Walmart had already
ceased selling ar-15s raise the age
limit to purchase a firearm or
ammunition to 21 required a green light
on a background check for purchases
instead of instead of the absence of a
red light which is required by federal
law among other steps so they've already
done all this stuff but now they're
gonna take it even further and stop
selling the ammunition for something
automatic weapons and they're asking
customers not to open carry in the in
the store so
got two different things we've got the
discontinuation of the sale of ammo for
semi-automatic firearms and then Walmart
not exactly banning people from open
carrying in their stores but requesting
that they don't a request that by the
way no matter how I feel about it I will
still say that all gun owners should
respectfully follow a request like that
that's definitely my view I think part
of being a responsible gun owner is that
if someone asks you not to bring your
gun into their home or into their
business you respect that those wishes
and either don't bring it in or don't
bring yourself in if you really can't
part with it for a few minutes you know
I think as gun owners it's very
important and there are gun owners who
make this mistake where they try to make
a statement with their gun or make a
spectacle of themselves with him and I
don't think we should do that I think
that's a mistake
there was this was a few years ago but
just one case I remember thing was at
Chipotle Chipotle few years ago
announced that you can't open carry in
their stores anymore because there had
been a group I think it was in Texas of
gun rights activists who were sort of
making a point of carrying you know
ar-15s and so on in such a polite so
they could eat their burritos not doing
just just for the spectacle just to make
a point and so Chipotle said no you
can't do that people are uncomfortable
and so no you can't bring it in and they
had every right to say that I think
actually that was a reasonable response
when you have customers that are
disrupting things and making people
uncomfortable for no reason not because
they're exercising their rights but just
because they're trying to make a
spectacle of themselves then I think the
company not only has every right to
respond but is reasonable in responding
and so it really annoys me as a lawful
gun owner myself when I do see gun
owners making spent making spectacles of
themselves on purpose and treating their
guns like toys
which does happen it's not common but it
happens that really really annoys me
because you're making it worse for the
rest of us the ammo thing on the other
hand is just silliness it's absolute
silliness there are many things in a
Walmart store that could kill you or
kill someone else if you abuse them okay
if you're walking into a Walmart and
thinking to yourself I want to buy
something that's gonna hurt somebody or
hurt myself you don't need to go to the
gun counter there are many other places
you could go
knives hammers ropes cleaning supplies
prescription pills pesticides I mean
there are a lot more people abusing some
of those things especially pills than
there are people abusing guns in fact
here's the real comparison we need to do
and I don't know the exact answer but I
have an educated guess here's what we
need to compare compare the people who
purchase prescription pills legally and
then abuse them to the people who
purchase guns and bullets legally and
then abuse them my educated guess is
that there are a lot more people in the
former category with the pills than
there are in a latter category because
the vast vast vast majority of legal
lawful gun owners are not hurting
anybody
yes Walmart has the right to make this
decision but it's a dumb decision with
no practical benefit in terms of
reducing gun violence and not to mention
you know you could say that well some
customers are uncomfortable now being in
a Walmart store with when there are guns
and so on around but I think there are a
lot of other customers who are
uncomfortable with the idea of being in
a Walmart store and being disarmed and
unable to defend themselves considering
what just happened at a Walmart but the
worst thing about it is that it
represents a cave to the left as I said
at the top which is symbolically very
damaging especially when Walmart is so
uniquely positioned to flip the bird to
the left and say we don't care what you
guys think it doesn't matter
you can't you can't touch us you can't
do anything to us you have no power over
us that's what we all need to start
saying and Walmart is able to say it but
they didn't hear on the issue of open
carrying in the stores and Kroger the
grocery store also just announced this
as well that they don't want you to open
carry in the store and this again is
stupid on a number of levels first of
all this is the main thing the shooting
in El Paso was not carried out by a
Walmart customer open carrying in the
store yes there was a shooting involving
a man with a gun in a Walmart but he was
not a Walmart customer who was open
carrying that's not what that was it
wasn't like you know someone who opened
carried in the store then got into an
argument in the self checkout line and
pulled out the gun and went on a
massacre okay if that's what had
happened then at least the open caring
policies would be relevant to the to the
situation but that's not what happened
this is someone who walked into the
store with the intention of killing
people not shopping and then he
proceeded to do it so once again
stopping people from open carrying in
the store that's not gonna prevent that
you're not gonna stop something just
because there's a sign saying don't open
carry in the store it's just like the
gun-free zone thing it's a cliche to
point it out but it's true that the
gun-free zone don't open carry all
you're doing is you're stopping the
people who are the sorts of people who
would respect rules like that and those
are all the good decent people but if
you're a psychotic killer and you want
to kill people you're not gonna care
about the policy and politely asking you
not to open carry in fact if anything
you are more likely to target a place
like that because you know that it's
unlikely anyone's gonna shoot back this
is really basic logic the left they they
claimed this is an unconvincing argument
but but where's the flaw in it if
someone is a potential mass shooter and
they're looking to carry this out and
they want to maximize casualties are
they
going to choose a place where there is
likely to be other gun owners there who
can return fire or are they going to
choose a place where it's likely people
are disarmed it's it's really obvious
they're gonna choose the latter in that
case alright moving on I wanted to talk
briefly about this first take a look at
at this image there you go that's the
picture there that is a a horse a
miniature horse named flirty and you
guessed that yes that is someone's
emotional support animal a woman brought
a horse on a flight
she bought a horse on a flight on an
American Airlines flight out of Chicago
because it's a service animal she claims
this really is I say it all the time
slippery slope arguments are constantly
vindicated in our culture which is
itself slipping down a very very big and
steep slide and so this is one of those
like you know five years ago people like
myself are saying hey with these
emotional so next thing you know people
are gonna be bringing horses on planes
and of course a lot of people's eyes I'm
not gonna do that well here we are
they're bringing a horse on a plane
she has depression and anxiety and this
is her service animal for those
conditions the woman a Brea Hensley is
her name says that she brings her
emotional support horse everywhere to
restaurants grocery stores movies only a
couple of times has she encountered an
establishment owned by someone with the
audacity to say hey would you mind not
bringing your horse inside can your
horse wait outside you have to bring it
inside and of course this this person
Abraha just a wonderful person is
looking at suing those places she says
that almost everywhere she goes with her
horse she's able to walk her out inside
and nobody complains everyone's fine a
few places in her life she's encountered
that where they say we'd prefer if you
don't and so what she gets she's gonna
sue them of course right
because she's going to sue them a
wonderful person
obviously right not at all an egomaniac
with no regard for anyone else who
expects everyone around her to
accommodate the utter absurdity of a
horse walking around inside oh wait yeah
that's exactly what she is right that's
what the emotional support animal stuff
really is much of the time that's the
real condition these people have that's
what they suffer from I know she says I
have anxiety depression PTSD the panic
attacks so on
she might have all that I'm not her
therapist but even as I'm even even
though I'm not her therapist or her
doctor
I can still diagnose her with this ego
mania she is a narcissist use an
egomaniac now I don't deny that service
animals are a real and necessary thing
for some people there are people with
real conditions who really do need a dog
with them I think dogs are the only
legitimate service animals and they
perform specific functions for people
who have real conditions and that's fine
a blind person for example needs a
seeing-eye dog obviously the dog
performs a specific function and it's
necessary for the person who suffers
from this disability to have the dog so
they can participate in society and and
and the animal helps facilitate that so
that's great that's fine
and I think it's wonderful that I think
it's amazing actually that dogs can are
able to do that for people but the idea
that you need your favorite animal with
you at all times
just emotionally even if the animal is a
horse or an iguana or three-toed sloth
or an ostrich the idea that you need
that medically for emotional reasons is
absurd I'm sorry it just is if you can't
emotionally deal with being separated
from your pet for a few hours you need
to grow up
okay that's what that's the real problem
here you need to be an adult
I mean I had to go through this with my
children and a lot of kids go through
this where they have their favorite
stuffed animal their favorite toy or
whatever and it's sort of in a security
blank and they like to bring it
everywhere but at a certain point as a
kid gets older you know if the kids two
years old and you likes the drag is
teddybear around everywhere for the most
part that's fine but when a kid is six
or seven they need to be able to go out
in public and go to school and do
whatever else without having that with
them and so and it can be a difficult
adjustment but you but you need to teach
them that so they can be so they can
grow up and mature and it's difficult
but kids can learn it if kids can learn
it then so can an adult so can a Brea or
a Dre or whatever her name is she can
learn it too she really can this you
know this is this is like emotional
blackmail and I'm really sick of it I'm
really sick of the emotional black one
where you have someone like this saying
well if you're like let me have my horse
with me I'm gonna freak out and panic
and sob and scream and cry on the plane
and so what would you rather have well
here's an option just don't act like
that control yourself I know you can
just don't how about a third of its not
let me bring my horse or I'm gonna freak
out and be a maniac no there's a third
option which is that you just function
like a normal like every other adult
everyone else in the world we can
somehow manage to walk around in board
planes and do things without a horse you
can too you really can I know you can
you can do it I believe in you look
mental illness is a real thing obviously
it's a real thing people deal with and
suffer from but I don't like how in in
so many cases in these days it's become
a cover to just be a self-absorbed jerk
now I know I say that and it's gonna be
misconstrued a million different ways
but if you're listening to me honestly
you understand what I'm saying
mental illness is a real thing but also
there are people who use the claims of
mental illness as emotional blackmail
and as an excuse
just act however they want and we're not
allowed to question it that also does
happen and it's a problem and I think a
prime example of that are these people
who say I'm gonna take this with this
animal and bring it with me everywhere
and you're not allowed to say anything
even if even if you it's your business
and you own it you can't tell me I can't
bring it with me
now I did see on Twitter in fairness how
this woman claims that the horse is is
not an emotional support animal actually
it's a service horse okay - sir it's a
service miniature horse and the main
service it provides is mobility
assistance I'm not kidding okay this is
what she claims that that miniature
horse in fact let's put the picture up
again that miniature horse is mobility
assistance for her I you know I I don't
think I need to explain why that is
ridiculous have you heard of a cane or a
walker or crutches I was on crutches for
two months I had a real condition and I
needed mobility assistance so I used
crutches or I had one of those nice
scooters okay I never occurred to me to
bring a horse around or a camel as much
as I would like to maybe now I would
next time I have an Achilles injury I'm
just gonna get a camel and ride my camel
everywhere and you're not allowed to say
anything I will bring my camel into your
home and you cannot stop me or I'll sue
you how exactly is a miniature horse
gonna stop you from falling down what is
it gonna do pad your fall break what is
it really what if you what is it gonna
do for you there are dozens of other
things that would be much better suited
for mobility assistance than a miniature
horse than a 3-foot tall horse but you
know we're all supposed to just go along
with it because the moment someone
claims disability or emotional distress
we all have to shut up and not our head
and say okay you do whatever you want no
no you know no I'm not I'm not gonna
play that we need to stop playing this
game at a certain point we can draw a
line and just call BS and say no you
don't need that horse but I do I have no
you don't you really don't I don't care
what you say you don't need it you just
don't stop grow up stop all right
here's one other thing before we get to
emails and I want to leave time for the
emails because I've got a I've got about
30 different emails on one particular
subject which if you listen to the show
yesterday maybe you can guess what the
subject is but we'll do that in a second
here's one other thing before we talk
about that another picture I want to
show you this has been the the day of
pictures rather than video clips this is
a new Calvin Klein marketing campaign
it's a it's a billboard if you're if
you're listening on iTunes
I'll just tell you I'm not trying to be
rude but but this is a well it's a large
woman apparently named chica ch i ka an
indie rapper it seems and she's sitting
there in her underpants and the message
says on the Billboard it says I speak my
truth in my in my Calvin's
I speak my truth in my Calvin's which
first of all if you are gonna speak your
truth do you need to do it in your
Calvin's it's okay to have your Calvin's
on but can you also wear red pants I
mean do you need to speak your truth and
your underwear I don't understand that
why do you need to have your underwear
on it's okay to have it on that's good
but you could also have clothes over top
it is what I'm trying to say and all I'm
gonna say here I could go in the
direction of how this is the
normalization of morbid obesity which is
a continued problem in our society and
it is dangerous because morbid obesity
is is will kill you and it's not a good
or healthy thing doesn't mean that if
you're morbidly obese doesn't mean that
you're a bad person or you know it's or
anything like that it's just it's just
it's an unhealthy physical condition and
so we shouldn't go out of our way to
normalize it or to celebrate it I think
that's a very reasonable point of view
that some of us have been
to express for a while now but I'm gonna
leave that aside what I just want to say
briefly is that the phrase speak my
truth is terribly terribly stupid and if
I could ban one phrase from being spoken
that would probably be it it would
either be that or that the term clap
back which you see even in headlines now
so and so claps back at critics really
terrible but speak my truth is even
worse for a number of reasons first of
all it's it's just it's cliched and
nonsensical and vapid and shallow and
dumb secondarily there is no such thing
as my truth so if you're speaking if
you're saying something you're either
saying something that is true or it
isn't I think every thought expressed in
the human language in any human language
is either true or not there is no my in
front of it it is either the truth or
even a truth or it's not or you could be
you could be lying you could be mistaken
you could be deluded whatever there's a
you you could be wrong for any number of
reasons but it's either wrong or it's
right you don't own the truth so there
could never be a scenario where you say
okay well that's that's not the truth
but it is my truth see that's just
another way of saying I'm wrong if
you're drawing a distinction between the
truth and your truth and you're noticing
that your truth is set up in opposition
with the truth then that's just you're
wrong that is a very convoluted and long
and and confusing way of saying I'm
wrong so there is no my truth that's all
not going to linger on it just wanted to
establish that all right Matt well show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
is email address as we get to emails I
yesterday if you listen to the show
I spoke for maybe five six minutes or so
about Harry Potter Harry Potter books
had been banned from a Catholic school
and I said that look I'm not a Harry
Potter fan at all I don't really care
about the books but I don't think
they're spiritually dangerous I don't
think that they need to be banned from
Christian schools I don't think they're
gonna cause kids to be possessed or
anything I don't think they're gonna
cause kids to you'll become Wiccans or
witches or warlocks or wizards I think
they are fantasy stories for kids like
Lord of the Rings but skewing younger
and not nearly as well-written that's
what I think of Harry Potter so I was
not approaching this as some rabid Harry
Potter fan
very passionate and defensive defending
Harry Potter no I think I took a pretty
moderate view which is I I don't really
care about the books I don't think that
they're terribly well-written or
anything but I just I don't think
they're gonna cause your kid to you know
start to getting into the occult or
anything like that that's that was kind
of my position in response I received
dozens of emails about Harry Potter
dozens and those are just my emails not
counting Facebook messages and Twitter
messages because then it would be triple
that and most of the messages from
people who strongly disagree with me and
strongly strongly strongly believe that
kids should should not read the books
because of the spiritual dangers and I
can't read all those emails I just kind
of kind of selected two at random and
I'll read those and and then I'll
respond okay this is from Nicki says
Matt your discussion of Harry Potter was
very disappointing I thought you were a
Christian question mark Harry Potter
influences children towards the occult
the spells in Harry Potter are real
Wiccan spells that the author learned it
is demonic that's why the school banned
the books do your research this is from
Cheryl says Matt sorry but totally
disagree with your take on Harry Potter
a well-known Exorcist priest father rip
injure spoke about it it's on YouTube
how a house was set set fire after
reading the HP books and declared that
they have real spells in them beyond
that if you don't believe those words
she went to school and studied
witchcraft in preparation for writing
the books and described her experience
as receiving the story plot ie it just
came to her so now I have to ask from
whom who inspired her writings as with
many modern-day portrayals of human
adult's in TV and fiction they muggles
aka non-magical people are portrayed as
bumbling blundering stupid and incapable
of understanding their child only the
magic people have any redeemable
characteristics I also have a real
problem with HP as a hero and literature
he is an antihero he lies he puts his
life and the lives of his friends
repeatedly at risk he disobey his
authority and although the threat is
there he has never punished for his lack
of virtue in fact
contrary his lack of virtue is rewarded
in his books so I asked you what message
is that sending to our young reader are
we not to encourage the true the good
and the beautiful in the formation of a
children's character
lastly the devil does not knock at your
door looking like Krampus he takes on
what many on many disguises so why
invite the father of lies into your home
if there is even a mite of truth to
these books being tainted why would you
allow them pass your threshold why when
there are so many virtuous alternatives
like George MacDonald have you read to
your children the princess and the
Goblin and my favorite the princess and
the curtain critic the princess and
Kerdi okay so and those were two you
know relatively reasonable emails
especially the second one the first one
questioning my faith and so on not very
reasonable second one was reasonable but
so there's there's a few different
things going on here first of all if you
make the argument that Harry Potter
doesn't belong in schools because it's
bad literature totally apart from the
morality and spirituality just it's just
not very well written and it's sort of
vapid and shallow and and all of that
and Harry Potter is not a worthy hero of
literature and just not together if
that's your argument then I say fine I'm
I haven't really read the books myself
so I get that that seems my impression
of the books is that they're not
terribly written well-written
certainly not at the level of something
with Lord of the Rings and so if that's
your criticism great I'm I'm on board
with that that's fine it's similar to I
would say that I don't think there
should be comic books in schools in the
school library or whatever I don't know
if schools have comic books but if they
do I would say no not because I think
that there's anything wrong with them
not because I think kids shouldn't be
reading them my kids love Mike my son
loves superheroes but just I I don't
think they're good enough literature to
be in schools I think schools should be
a place for better literature than that
and when the kids are at home if they
want to spend their time reading
book a reading Harry Potter that's fine
that's my impression so that's I'm gonna
put those criticisms to the side because
I agree with those and that's a totally
different conversation the copy the the
claims though about the spiritual
aspects that's where I just I don't buy
it first of all
a house was set fire after reading the
Harry Potter books what does that mean
was it did it just burst into flames on
its own or was the child inspired to set
the house on fire I haven't heard of
this case you know what I do know is
then I did look it up I did I didn't see
any support for that other than the fact
that this one guy claimed it that's the
kind of look if you're gonna claim that
a house spontaneously burst into flames
because someone read Harry Potter I just
I need a lot of evidence for that I mean
I'm not gonna just believe it because
somebody said it mainly because first of
all it's I don't see the connection how
reading a book could make a house be set
on fire so there appears to be a just
sort of metaphysically here there's a
disconnect but second secondly billions
of these books have been sold and so if
they had that effect shouldn't we see
houses bursting into flames all over the
place yet that's not what we observe in
fact what we observe in almost every
case is that people read Harry Potter
then they go and live their lives and
nothing happens and so that would seem
to indicate that there's probably not
much of a problem here at the very least
if you're going to claim that it has
this magical power to it and it can
cause things like that to happen again
I'm gonna need real evidence of that and
I'm and the claim of one person is not
to me evidence just isn't because that
person could be wrong that could be
exaggerating they could be lying there I
mean there any number of things they
could be believing a rumor they heard a
lot of different ways a person could be
wrong so we have to ask ourselves what's
more likely that this
father Ripper juror is just mistaken
about the house being set on fire
because of Harry Potter or that it
actually happened so there's that the
idea that these that their real magical
spells in Harry Potter I did look that
up also I found no support for that
claim other than the fact that this
particular priest and a couple other
people have asserted it so I saw the
assertion that these are real magical
spells I didn't find any other support
for that anywhere maybe it's there I
didn't find it all I found is this this
assertion repeated and there's a
difference between an assertion being
repeated and actual evidence of it now
in what I would consider to be slightly
more objective sources what I found is
that the spells in Harry Potter consists
of faux Latin and gibberish and then
also magic wands being waved around
isn't it but they aren't the don't you
need the wand for the magic canary
Potter hunter that's what I saw and that
is not what you find among Wiccans and I
don't pretend to be an expert of Wiccans
I don't want to be an expert but that's
that's it's not these are not actually
Wiccan spells that's what I saw I saw no
evidence to the contrary in fact I did
read a couple things from actual Wiccans
saying that's not true that's not what
we do I don't like citing Wiccans as
experts but if we're looking for an
expert on Wiccan ISM then probably
they're the place to go they'll probably
tell us and they're saying that's not
what we do
that's not how spells work with Wiggins
the other thing is you know the very
idea of a real magical spell now I
believe that there are actual evil
forces at work in the universe and that
they do exist but that's that's quite
apart from claiming that a magical spell
is real the idea that certain syllables
just have this power that if you put
them together things are going to happen
physically in the world
not sure that I believe that in fact I
don't believe that I think that you know
something like prayer okay obviously you
can pray and that can have a real
physical effect but that's not a magical
spell and even someone who is trying to
conjure you know get in touch with
demons and so on and that's a real thing
I I wouldn't call that a magical spell
either so when we talk about magical
spells I think we're specifically
talking about you know like in a in a
movie or a book where someone reads
certain syllables and it doesn't matter
the intent it doesn't matter anything
just if you if you read those words this
happens I don't think that exists period
doesn't exist and if it does exist then
again I would need real evidence of that
and I don't not aware of any evidence so
my main contention with Harry Potter
that I don't think and and I did I
didn't read every email I read a lot of
them but my main contention with Harry
Potter was that I I don't see it as that
much different from Lord of the Rings I
think it's the same kind of thing except
for it's not as well written and it's
just not as good of a story so there's
that difference but in both cases you
have evil of good and evil forces you
have magical spells you have witches and
warlocks and wizards it's the same kind
of thing and as I said yesterday what
would make for me Harry Potter morally
troubling is if the the evil spirits
were portrayed as good or if it was a
nihilistic kind of situation where there
was no difference between the evil and
good that then I would say yeah that's a
problem and I wouldn't want my kids
reading that so that's that's the
difference but I don't think that's what
you'll find in Harry Potter
now the other attempt at a response that
I saw from some people is they said well
the difference is in Lord of the Rings
the the magical people are wizards not
humans and so so it's it's less of a
problem because if kids are reading Lord
of the Rings and they understand that
these are we
not human beings and so real humans
can't do that and so it's but again I I
just don't that's a distinction I don't
understand the significance of that
distinction Harry Potter is a book where
in the world of that fantasy book some
human beings can do these things I think
children if they're old enough to read
Harry Potter they're old enough to
understand that it's a fantasy it's not
real and in the real world people can't
do it it's it's it's just like with
superheroes in a superhero story some
human beings have the power to do to do
you know magical things I think children
are capable of understanding that that's
not real it's not the reality it's just
a story so I just I I'm going to have to
maintain it's weird that I'm here
defending Harry Potter because as I said
I'm not even a fan of it but I don't see
the I just don't see the significant
moral difference between Harry Potter
and other fantasy stories all right
let's see what else does anything else
anything not Harry Potter related no not
really everything's Harry Potter so I
think I've I think I've kind of
addressed that well here's one agreeing
with me I wanted to find is there at
least one person who agrees yes this is
from Melissa says hello Matt just wanted
to say I totally agree with your take on
Harry Potter we have two sons 23 and 19
we are devout Christians and when our
old older son was of the age where he
became interested in reading the Harry
Potter series I was leery because of the
bad press the series had received in
Christian circles I decided to read them
myself first in order to formulate an
opinion based on first-hand knowledge
and not hearsay
I enjoyed the books and really didn't
understand what all the hubbub was about
my husband and I did make sure they
understood that the magic wasn't real
and that books are fantasy but they knew
that already if kids can understand the
difference between fact and fiction the
school and parents have have more to
worry about than Harry Potter enjoy your
show appreciate your voice for conserved
principles yeah that's that's it if your
kids kids that's the whole thing about
well the Lord of the Rings it's you know
in Harry Potter the problem is it's real
people doing this and so kids are gonna
think
you think your kid can understand that
it's just a story you can't really do
that so if you teach your kid that it's
not a problem and I don't think it's
significant problem where kids are gonna
read Harry Potter and then say oh gee I
want to go become a Wiccan or I want to
I want to you know get into a cult
things I'm now that I'm sure you could
find me examples I'm sure you could find
me anecdotal examples of people who read
Harry Potter and then became Wiccans I
absolutely expect that you can find
those examples and I'm sure that now
people will send them to me but I'm sure
you'll also find examples of people who
read Lord of the Rings and then went off
and said I want to be a real warlock or
witch or wizard or whatever I'm sure
that also has happened are we sure that
Harry Potter more often has had that
effect then has say Lord of the Rings it
seems to me with most of the criticisms
criticisms of Harry Potter even if the
people making the criticisms try to draw
a distinction it seems to me that most
of these criticisms are really just
criticisms against the entire fantasy
genre where you're saying look I don't
think there should be any stories that
deal with evil spirits and conjuring
black magic and all that I don't think
there should be any of that now if
that's your argument I think it's a very
puritanical and frankly kind of silly
argument but then at least it make it
consistent I think when you tried it
when you when you make the argument on
those broad terms of saying well it's
just better not to mess with this stuff
it's evil spirits and so on if you say
that but then say oh but Lord of the
Rings sure that's fine now to me it
appears to be kind of special pleading
and it's it's just it's it's not
consistent I think to be consistent you
have to make that argument and rule out
all of those kinds of books which there
are some Christians who feel that way
and especially historically that has
been a you know there have been a
significant number of Christians
historically who have felt that way and
have said that there shouldn't be any of
that kind of stuff so if that's your
argument then then you don't make that
your argument
all right so so much for Harry Potter
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching
god speed the Matt Walsh show is
produced by Robert Sterling associate
producer alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
his Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]